good morning Millennials what does that
me or you mrs. lovell I was looking at
CEO jet in the eye you said man I just
gave up let's try that again nothing
matters in the face of video one good
morning Millennials wow I'm so good but
I don't know it's weird you know what
we're one hour back today like I can't
be expected to be the same self I would
be if the clocks hadn't been changed I'm
feeling it I know I know they say like
you travel like just she went from
Dallas the one-hour jetlag doesn't get
to you but I beg to differ
I'm feeling the one hour difference no
like I absolutely loathe losing this
hour me too except for the fact that now
it's brighter out later but you know
whatever is really nice but I read a
really fascinating article this weekend
about how dealings daylight savings time
and changing your internal body clock
one hour forward right on our back it's
so bad for you it causes heart attacks
in people and some states are trying to
stop daylight savings because it's
deadly I mean I couldn't agree more I
was feeling so I mean to have us lose
one hour is injustice enough but to do
it on International Women's Day it's
just a real kick in the ass like as if
we didn't feel you know subpar already
yeah just take out that one hour bird we
should be celebrating ourselves and then
on a Sunday nonetheless like why not on
a Monday why not on a Monday okay I
think if the states I can't get them to
revoke daylight savings time completely
which I think that they should
considering it's a deadly holiday it's a
scientific holiday it's like the the
lunar year is not really 365 days it's
365 days and six hours so every four
years oh wait no that's a leap years
yeah I don't know the daylight savings
thing no it's like because of the time I
miss thinking we're where we revolve
around the Sun like we just have to I
don't know [ __ ] around with the clock I
have no idea you know what I think in
the grand scheme of things it's not a
huge feel no because like we say during
lives are being lost over it yeah I
think it's time we rescind and it seems
like we're giving ourself this problem
like we have to lose an hour because we
gave ourselves the our last year don't
we remember that so it's like it's
our fault yeah so why don't we stop
ticking and then give it thing away yeah
I think that this you know this is an
archaic thing but people are saying that
for people that have kids we need it to
be dark by 7:00 p.m.
by the way I don't hate that it gets
dark early because it's time for bed
like I know this season I really felt it
like watches it's because now I have a
nice big window in my bedroom that I
stare at all day and when it gets dark
it like makes me sad maybe with the
light the longer it stays lighter out
the longer I could be happy I just think
that the darkness like isn't such a bad
thing yeah I agree with that but I do
think daylight savings is a terrible
thing and it's just like taking lives
and it needs to be stopped I just think
it's kind of toxic and I we went to
dinner on Saturday night we got home it
was the longest dinner ever I got home
at like 1:00 I watched a little bit of
SNL which I have to say I've seen a lot
of SNL episodes and it was one of the
worst agreed except the weekend was
spectacular what Daniel Craig was great
but I totally disagree I'm terrible I
loved him on the sketch about the James
Bond scene where they're all gambling
that was sunny that was you by the way
that was funny for sure but that was a
pre-recorded segment which is supposed
to be his live monologue yeah it's
Saturday Night Live not Saturday night
pre-recorded I just I guess I'm one of
those women who likes Daniel Craig so
like a hundred percent of women I like
no I like him - I just thought it wasn't
good I didn't think he did a good job
and it didn't make sense that he was
hosting they've pushed I know but what
are they gonna do he was the hope I know
it was just I really thought it was such
a bad episode the writing was bad and
Daniel Craig was bad it was a really
really bad episode I stayed up until the
first performance same and then I turned
three I am fell asleep and then we
finished it in the morning and I was
like this is not how I want to start my
day
no but watching SNL turning around
saying it's 3:00 a.m. was a shift to the
system which could give you a heart
attack I think that's actually the
definition of a heart attack is a shake
to your system yeah so I guess wouldn't
say I'm anti daylight savings the fact
that like it's technically 9:34 means
that it is not time it is not time no I
should not be here right now neither
should you and I woke up this morning
and like I overslept obviously obviously
because my internal body clock was like
Jay me too I mean can you blame yourself
no I didn't realize I never
sleeeeep I didn't realize that's what I
look like [ __ ] but I didn't realize that
the cause of my over sleeping was
probably daylight savings good call yeah
that's exactly why and look Jake
imagine how CEO feels with no one to
explain to him what's going on yeah and
you like mom why is it dark out and I
don't even have the heart to explain to
him at the world is against him
yeah like CEO missed his alarm it was so
sad he had to get ready in a huff look
at him tears in his eyes
oh oh my god he's too cute we're having
an N do today and it couldn't be a more
beautiful day for an NDA yeah I'm
letting Jackie take care of Theo because
I have a mmm photo shoot ha ha ha how
long have you been like excited to say
that I mean know what I don't want to
forget it out but I have to photo shoots
this month that's so exciting I mean
they're gonna get to the point we were
calling them shoots you know I'm so not
even there yet but I'm getting close I
feel like I have a lot of secret
projects some of them not so secret
anymore and a lot of them involve photo
shoots so just get ready like see me on
the cover of magazines I'm so ready do
you think so yeah I was born ready are
you ready to like go get him out of here
to see her sister like sitting on the
waiting table for sure and I'll get a
manicure on an NGO and I can be like -
Theo oh my god that's mommy that's why
you're here with me she's too busy
making millions to feed you it is you
know 1 million degrees in New York today
and I'm really not about that life I
love the winter and I know that spring
is coming and that means like shorts are
like I just got out of my shorts and I
have to put the bag on yeah I've been
struggling to get dressed all winter and
I feel like this happens every winter
where I don't buy like close for the
season early enough and then it's like
February March I'm like I'll just wait
for spring so I have all these spring
clothes all these like dumb crop tops
that I hate and no winter clothes but
I'm gonna spring into spring I'm gonna
do it speaking of spring clothes we have
a spring workshop coming up in the next
couple a couple weeks and it's some
really good [ __ ] so get yourselves ready
thickening stuff and you know what maybe
we're running out of things to wear
because we haven't done a merged shop in
a while I mean I literally came to work
today in ugly-ass sweater and I changed
into a piece of merch because like merch
is what it is I almost wore merch today
as well but then I was gonna wear a
thigh high boots and I was like but it's
n do what if we're walking anyway flats
this is a black old English I don't know
if it's still available but you head
over to shop morning toast com2 check it
out it's also available in white so
between black or white one of them has
to be available okay well even though
it's daylight savings time it's
definitely not I'm I'm just gonna go
ahead with this farce that the farmers
have put on and let you know that it is
time for the classified stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning
toast and that's true I don't want to
you know step on anyone's toes be like
oh my god it's time but then it's like
not time because then it's like so
disrespectful and kind of hypocritical
of me but I know you'll be really
excited because today's episode is
brought to you by function of beauty
Jackie's literally literal favorite
brand
it's my little favorite brand because I
just got a new freshest shipment and I
switched up my order because I just like
was in the mood to shake things up
Chicago know like with the new time like
you have to shake things up Chicago
right so I just want to let you know
what I did for my function of UT because
I think it's brilliant and I'm really
excited it actually is really smart so
you let them know like what you want out
of your shampoo and conditioner so I let
them know I want shiny hair like my hair
is broken I want healthy hair I also
like weirdly have dry scalp you take a
four question quiz when you are the
website about like what type of shampoo
you like to use what your hair style is
yes so I told them all the things that I
wanted and you can also pick a scent in
your shampoo and I know sometimes people
like to go fragrance free because like
added fragrances you know it's just
perfumes and it can't be great for you
but I love a fragrance shampoo so I got
both my shampoo and conditioner to be
eucalyptus scented I swear I felt like
it was in the spa it's the small things
that can just make you feel so luxurious
and you color-coded them so not only did
I do all of that but I got you can color
your shampoo and conditioner and you
would think okay I'll get them both to
be pink but then I was like know what my
bathroom is like teal so I got one blue
one green shampoo they both match one
green conditioner they both match my
bathroom and that way I can know which
one shampoo and which ones conditioner
without having to read the bottle which
has been my cross to bear my whole life
my whole life we all know the
frustration bottles and bottles of half
used shampoo and conditioners each one
promising to be everything your hair
ever needed but they lied to you you
deserve better try function of beauty if
you're ready to live your best hair life
in 2020 its internet top internet's top
rated customized hair care brand with
over 30,000 five-star customer reviews
and Counting to begin the 4 question
quiz and save 20% off on your purchase
go to function of beauty calm / toast
tell them about your hair customize your
formula with fragrance and color you can
go dye free and fragrance free the
products are so personalized your name
is even printed on the bottle and all
the products are vegan and cruelty free
they never use sulfates parabens flat
lights
mineral oils or any other harmful
ingredients to get started now go to
function of beauty.com / chose to take
your 4 part hair profile quiz and
20 percent off your first order don't
spend another minute in her misery go to
function of beauty calm / toast to let
them know that we sent you that's
function of beauty calm / toast sign on
get shampoo that's very much your
aesthetic I used it last night so if you
think my hair is looking good today
that's how the function of beauty
swagger okay first up a fart Chapman
like no other that is just taking the
world by storm give me a minute because
I can't breathe let alone speak okay
first up Amanda Bynes and her fiance
Paul Michael break up just weeks after
their engagement devastating devastating
it's over for Amanda Bynes and her
fiance Paul Michael just three weeks
after announcing their engagement the
couple has broken up a news reported
they reportedly met last year this is
not the kind of instability and madness
buy-ins needs like she needs a man she
know what she needs a businessman beau
and does she need a man or is she's the
man who interesting question you posed
yeah I think that she might be the man I
don't know I feel like she actually
doesn't need a man when I think about
her I think she needs a friend no I
think she needs like a really good
support system and foundation look at
their life maybe a set of friends at her
sister's so they know how to like give
her that sisterly love we could never be
friends with amanda Bynes after what we
did to her that's true
no but like I have a lot of like shame
and guilt about that night yeah we just
we didn't know we were just being like
annoying fans yeah like we saw her at a
club and it happened to be like in the
middle of a spiral for her we didn't
know we just thought she was at a club
and a pop it was it actually an event it
was a nylon magazine party so there was
like photographers everywhere but one
photographer like got in who wasn't a
real photographer it was a paparazzi and
was taking pictures of Amanda like in a
club booth and she was not happy about
it and she chased the photographer out
of the club and security got this poor
photographer like hand over her SD card
it was like so sad and Jackie and I
literally followed around a security
guard amanda bynes and the paparazzi
like the whole time just like seeing
what was going do you think like we were
actually trying to help like like we
were just we wanted to be part of it but
we were also trying to help get that
camera yeah I just I don't remember that
the ends justify the means
I just remember like wanting to be
involved in the drama and to really been
justifying that means on the show don't
you think I think these days it's so
important that your ends do justify your
means because if they're not justifying
what are you doing Oh
for sure it's out of control but you
think in general the ends do justify the
means it depends who you are for me
maybe not all the time like I think I do
things like so recklessly I'm and don't
realize after like till that they were
[ __ ] up or like I wish that I hadn't
like you know thrown the lady gang book
like sometimes like that but I would you
honestly that's a goal of mine is to be
one of those people whose ends always
justify their means got it you know
that's really the moral of the story of
the show the politician or the question
that it poses yeah like do his ends
justify his means because in the end he
wants to do good for everyone but he has
like he does bad things in order to be
able to do good for people yeah but like
remember that scene in the bathroom
where they're like his campaign manager
is like making fun of that kid who
happens to be in the bathroom yeah and
it's like every and then Pilate he was
like not an [ __ ] even when no one was
listening he was like every kid deserves
to be heard yeah but then when it's like
he knew about Zoey Deutsch like thank
you so we're in but that part of the
whole that whole part of politician
really bothered me like someone else is
[ __ ] it's not my [ __ ] problem
Sheriff they like culture these days
where you're responsible for like what
people you know do and say someone
else's [ __ ] it's just not my problem
not like I didn't take this dump I'm not
flushing it okay totally ok next story
is something that I'm really excited to
talk about breezy ok because I just this
is what I've been waiting to talk about
wait can I say our YouTube comments have
been like off the charts this week I
think with all the guests like we were
bringing in naan toasters and this is
this was actually a comment from a
toaster who was like I read the first
sentence I was like oh my god what
should we do she was so disappointed in
us for breezing through the stories oh
yeah I saw that too they were like no
she was like been watching since the
breath and she was really disappointed
in Friday's episode because we breezed
through the stories and it's like the
episode was over an hour so I can't we
breezed through the stories and it's
because like the situation and mrs.
situation when raining down Sarah's like
we've got to get on with the show
yeah I just felt like last week I think
maybe part of what we were feeling on
Friday well I was feeling on Friday like
really down on myself had to do a lot
with the fact that we had so many extra
viewers last week from the guests
audience that like were saying mean
things about me like when you first you
know when you first got to know me and
maybe that's what it was
maybe we spoke about this a lot actually
Jack and I both recorded episodes of
mood with Lauren Elizabeth because
Lauren was in town this weekend so she
recorded episodes with both Jackie and I
separately so they'll be going up I
think in the next two weeks yeah they
were actually really good cuz we talked
about a lot of stuff that like we don't
harp
here on this show just like basically
mood and wellness and like what we do to
take care of ourselves and just like
mental health and I think it's actually
really interesting you did get a spray
tan at my at my behest I did and I went
to the place that I always go to and you
know I got recognized in the reception
for being on say yes to the dress which
is like my like it is my claim to fame
and I'm so upset about it like and she
was like asking me so many questions
like about she actually worked in TV so
she was like I understand I'm like
girlfriend it was not nothing of the
sort
I actually don't think I mentioned on
the show how we always talk about my
nothing of the sort experience on say
yes to the dress and recently I got an
email from the producer who booked me on
it and she's a toaster and she was like
I die every time you talk about it like
obviously had nothing to do with editing
like I just cast you on it cause like I
loved you so Hayley like no hard
feelings but I did get me a free spray
tan is what I was trying to take when we
were at LA we are at a fabulous party
and a woman came up to us and she was
like she was looking at me so weird and
she didn't look like a typical toaster
just was like toast her eyes but not a
toaster vibe and so she was like oh my
god I loved you on say yes to the dress
which you get a lot because it was I
don't get I don't get I love it even
though it was you wasn't your favorite
portrayal of yourself like you were
still great in as a funny episode yeah
and she was just like I loved your
sister Lee bonds right so at least
remember did she remember me even though
my hair is like so I was the length and
she had only lovely things to say about
the episode so I hope that makes you
feel differently even I know that it
doesn't it didn't but what did make me
feel differently is it got me a free
spray tan at bronze boutique so thanks
I'm happy for you and the spray tan
really didn't make a difference in my
weekend like how I felt about myself
I'm so glad about that okay well this
story just like with everything on the
sort this weekend inside the
kardashian-jenner family's fun-filled
trip to Palm Springs
did you watch all the Instagram stories
of course oh my god
what a time fabulous I mean I've never
really wanted to go to Palm Springs
because I have a lot of post-traumatic
stress disorder from like the weekends I
spent there like gee wandering the
desert at Coachella
but I definitely could spend the weekend
at kris Jenner's house totally so the
whole family all the sisters and the
kids Kris and Cory took to Palm Springs
for the weekend and they just had a day
and a night and it looked like
everything of the sort some would say
they even looked fabulous
it looked so fabulous they were day
drinking they were night drinking they
went to two cans
to watch a drag show yes sisters were
dancing and singing and you know they're
not much for dancing and they're not
much for clubbing Chloe used to in but
Kylie does yeah but they're not really
like Club brats and they were like
sitting at a table with like bottles
like I was just dying they were just
having so much fun I absolutely loved
watching the whole weekend
I mean we're filming the whole thing Kim
had her Instagram like on fleek she was
not about to have another sauce-i moment
like after each Queen performed Kim was
like tagging this is violet chachki like
yes tagging everyone because she learned
her salsa lesson yeah no it was great
and then Chloe got on the mic thanked
everyone for loving them Kylie sing rise
and shine dead it was just it looked
like so fun it made me want to take a
trip and it made me realize that we
can't take a trip no and I was actually
thinking this morning about our trip to
Vegas that we have planned in April what
are we gonna do um so I think what we're
gonna do is we're gonna wait it out if
the concert gets cancelled which it
might then we'll cancel our trip but by
then hopefully all the airlines will
have more lenient policies towards
cancelling your flight I got an email
from Delta last night long and it had
absolutely nothing in it it was just
like we're aware and thanks like where's
the flexibility Delta I think we ride it
out until they give us that flexibility
which they absolutely have to another
fart chairman has come my way listen the
other long morning and you like
embarrassing him on air he actually
talked to me about it last night because
I said you know you're going to your
aunt's house tomorrow for a nice day he
said oh you mean the end who's always
embarrassing me on my show he called it
his show which was crazy sick and he
said like can you stop putting me on
blast okay but so I'm just supposed to
suffer through the fart camera it's like
I can't I can barely speak oh the baby's
going in my mouth was sitting with me
and you're the one who totally kidnapped
him so like that's the price you pay I
cannot you guys saw it we have footage
we have the tape if you want a Pheo and
like you have to live that's life no I
know listen I'm just saying like if I'm
not speaking it's just cuz I don't want
to get a fart tremon trapped in my coat
okay I'm just telling you looking women
theall gets home from your house today
like I think he's gonna cry because you
married some again okay so Kylie and
Travis are back together I know but like
I didn't really need this full
confirmation I just figured that they
were and I don't really feel like they
ever really like broke up in an official
capacity because they always were
co-parent co-parenting store me so well
that I felt like they never really like
fully broke up they were just like on
and off but I don't care like I know
that there's happy and I'm happy about
it I didn't need a TMZ
even though when something Kardashian
related comes from TMZ you know it's a
hundred percent true because Kris Jenner
is actually Harvey wines excuse me
Harvey Levin oh my god imagine um Kylie
is just having the time of her life
right now looking so sickening and
everything that she does and just like
drinking having a blast I love the
relationship between the girls in Corey
like he really is the MVP he isn't you
know he had to deal with a good amount
like on the show they made him out in
the beginning cuz they weren't sure what
he was like all about they made him out
to be a little creepy yeah and also it's
not like they just accepted him you know
open arms like they definitely doubted
him doubted him and you know put him
through the wringer but now they
obviously love him and I love that for
them yeah I I really like I always liked
it I love it for Chris like because she
deserves so much happiness she deserves
happiness she's been through a lot I
think he plays a lot of roles he wears a
lot of hats he's like cool Corey gamble
like getting invited to Justin Bieber
like he's a bro wedding but he's also
like a grandfather now he's like he's
loving he's mr. lovey and he's mr. love
he wears it quite well he does he really
does and I think he's loving life it's
just so weird when Chris started dating
someone for the first time after Bruce
like you just thought it was probably
going to be a fling but it's like it
ended up being like the greatest love
story of our generation some might say I
I think I would feel comfortable saying
that I think I would say that too okay
are you ready for our next story I don't
know
speaking of Cory Gamble's got me like
you know all Thursday do you have
something that you want to share about
your thirst I'm just feeling a little
dehydrated which isn't new for me so
they have such a hard time drinking
water which is why liquid IV it's been
the perfect sponsor for the show and
everyone's talking about their hydration
multiplier you've heard how much we love
it but have you heard about their latest
product the energy multiplier liquid
Ivy's energy multiplier tastes amazing
just like their lemon-lime flavor mix it
with water and drink their energy
multiplier gives you sustain energy
boost with no crash I'm a daylight
savings just coming and taking hours out
of your life you never know when you're
gonna need to be on and the energy
multipliers everything you need one of
the things we love so much is that
they're on a mission to change the world
they've donated two million servings to
date to places like Haiti Uganda Puerto
Rico and Nepal with each purchase you
make liquid IV donates a serving to
someone in need around the world you can
do good and feel good what's not to love
a half of Americans report that they
fight with daily fatigue so true the
word fatigue is just like my life
maybe you recognize some of the signs of
low energy decreased focus lack of
motivation of poor mood so may
unhappiness who wants that their energy
multiplier gives you sustained energy
throughout the day fight the fatigue
without the crash it's a perfect
replacement for morning coffee I don't
drink coffee on an all-natural end it's
an all natural alternative to processed
dregs they have premium matcha and green
energy blend that they taste delicious
and provide a lasting energy boost
throughout the day get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV calm and use the code
toast at checkout that 25% off anything
you order on liquid IV's website but
that's only if you use the code toast
just go to liquid IV com enter the promo
code toast to save 25% get better
hydration and energy don't wait start
fueling your adventurous today hydration
is everything liquid IV just makes it
quicker easier and tastier hydration is
everything you said it says okay this
next story I absolutely I'm so obsessed
with this is the first time I'm hearing
it it's just like another couple that I
can add to the list of like Ariana and
Jim Carrey even though that speculation
Georgina and Adrien Brody okay and now
Ben Affleck and Ana de Armas and if
you're not familiar with who she is
he's from knives out and she's also
gonna be in the new James Bond movie
whenever it comes out if you're not
familiar with her she wore that sequin
Navy strapless dress and Russo to the
Oscars and it was absolutely sickening
and she stole the show she stole the
show she's in knives out she steals that
shows actually a warrant out for her
arrest for stealing the show she's so
stunning so kind I'm so obsessed at this
couple I just don't know if Ben
Affleck's like in a place yet where he
can like be in a good stable
relationship I hope that he is I feel as
though he is Ben Affleck and knives out
actress Ana de Armas are continuing
their romantic getaway together a source
tells people that the pair left Havana
on Saturday night and we're seeing
making out in the airport before they
boarded their private jet quote they are
definitely dating the source says on
Thursday Affleck 47 and de Armas 31
which is I was curious about their age
is a market but she looks so much
younger good for her were spotted while
out to eat and walking around Havana
where de Armas is from they were
pictured smiling and laughing on a walk
around the Cuban capital by
photographers and fans who asked to take
photos with the stars in one group
picture de Armas stood in front of
athletic as they smiled while surrounded
by fans another photo from a different
outing this time at a restaurant seemed
to show the two with the chef of the
restaurant
okay they totally spent the weekend
together in her hometown that is so
adorable mm-hmm and I don't know I know
we live in a free country but I think we
have absolutely no choice here but to
San yeah no we have no choice and why
would you even want to choice I
absolutely ship and even though like I
can't get on the ship because of
coronavirus and it would just like get
stuck there for devastating um I'm so
excited about this new couple I'm so
excited for him like because I think he
has really done a lot of work on himself
and he's ready for a relationship
yeah and she's a precious gem of a woman
yeah I find this to be like an
interesting choice for her because she's
really like having her moment like this
is every like award season there's like
a star that comes out of it a few years
ago as Alicia vikander I remember she
chose Michael Fassbender like they
always choose one I think Ben Affleck is
an interesting choice
he's not an obvious choice cuz he's been
through a good amount you never want to
make an enemy of Jennifer Garner but
here she is yeah I think I I love it
saying Jennifer Garner's in a
relationship and she's happy so I'm not
gonna like you know feat I'm not gonna
think about her in this instance no but
part of me does still hold out like a
small amount of hope for that family to
get back together only because their
daughter is named after the most
wonderful restaurant Seraphina I agree
with that until I saw this story today
and for me this is it and I have
absolutely no choice but to chef I'm
really happy like for him I think that
this is the best girl he could have
gotten I do think she could have done a
little better okay but like when you say
that and you think that then it's like
oh wow she could have done better yet
she's with him it must be true love yeah
for sure no no it's all good it's all
good it's all good it must be true love
it must be like that's the thing it has
like when something doesn't make sense
there's no reason to explain it other
than true love Jordan woods Tristan
Thompson but we know that it wasn't true
love but if it was true love the whole
thing would have made sense yes oh also
this isn't a story that I do want to
talk about the fact that a Gaston origin
film has just been announced a prequel a
prequel with Josh cab Josh GAD and Luca
Evans and I'm so excited we also
predicted it here at the show but it's
just an amazing idea and I'm I'm I'm so
happy that it's happening because you
know Gaston is a complex fellow he is
he's not likely to take a wife oh my god
I wish you watch friends I was such a
good reference
Chandler's a complex fella who's not
likely to take a wife well Gaston was a
complex fella who's not likely to take a
wife and I'm curious to see how he
became so complex
yeah I
- okay what the names gonna be maybe
Gaston we don't so good yeah that might
have been like our best that was the
best of everyone
it's always about everyone next door is
kind of crazy there's a lot of just like
shade being thrown Justin Bieber's
changes tore down grades to smaller
venues amid slow sales this is so
interesting Justin Bieber is squeezing
some of the concerts on his news tour
into smaller venues because of slower
than expected ticket sales some of the
larger shows planned on the yummy
singers upcoming changes tour have not
been selling well and sources say he and
management made the strategic decision
to downsize some concerts in smaller
markets to avoid heavy losses on the
forty five date torte ate stadium shows
were moved to smaller arenas for his
first outing since the 2017 purpose tour
the announced shift came the same day
that Austin Mayor Steve Adler announced
he was canceling South by Southwest amid
concerns over the spread of coronavirus
fear of the illness have caused serious
nervousness in the live music world
although Live Nation CEO Michael Rapinoe
noted on the company's fourth-quarter
earnings call On February 27th that
sales were up 10% for the first two
months of 2020 can I just say like not
to make everything about me
how wonderful was the timing of my tour
yes like not that I just wouldn't want
to be dealing with this because I'm sure
that ticket sales weren't great for a
ver myriad of reasons maybe one of them
being Justin Bieber hasn't been seen for
the last four years but coronavirus is
definitely a factor yeah it's not the
only factor no but it's like if there
was a concert that I wanted to go to now
and we did silly done no no I mean say
tickets were coming out for a summer
concert that I want to go to tickets
come out tomorrow I don't know that I
would buy a ticket right now I might
wait till closer to see what happens
because it might just get cancelled oh
that's true but I wouldn't I wouldn't
not buy it for fear of getting cancelled
because if you're buying it it's gonna
get refunded like that's not my concern
my concern would be like buying it and
then not wanting to go write that too
but um Billboard notes that virus fears
don't appear to have hurt other big pop
tours BTS similar sized map of the Seoul
stadium tour is nearly sold out I mean
we just went to Celine Dion and I guess
that Herc tour was announced over a year
ago and the tickets sold over a year ago
but you would think maybe it would have
impacted attendance but it was
completely packed yeah nobody
hasn't hit yet and I think that this is
different like the way where you behave
like this week next week is gonna be
very different from where we're at this
summer it could be that this summer you
know the concern is gone but I think
people are now planning going forward
like if you had a trip plan for this
weekend you might still take it but I
wouldn't book a trip for it in two
months from now yeah no if I had a trip
planned this week and I probably would
still go I would love to be going
somewhere this weekend but just taking
precautions I think I watched um this
segment that would envira love dr. drew
they have real dr. drew talking about
how the media is to blame like for this
panic and that it's really not as bad as
people are making it seaman he blames
the media and I'm honestly I believe dr.
drew he was very compelling and it's
incas like the CDC is telling you
conceal you can still travel and TPG was
on CBS this morning and he was like you
can still travel like so I feel like the
panic is a little panicky which is good
but I think like people are taking steps
to be overly cautious and at the end of
the day the the hysteria might be just
that maybe but then I see things where
it's like I know Twitter thread that
this woman who's like a scientist
explaining what will happen when it
exponentially when the virus grows
exponentially as it has been and like
that we don't have enough beds and
enough masks in this country oh my god
see like I don't know but she was using
like facts I don't know no I know I keep
hearing like really compelling arguments
from both sides still want to travel I
want to like you know support the
tourist economies live your life then
someone said to me what if you leave the
country yep and then the country goes
under quarantine and you can't get back
in and you can't get home even leaving
like the city what if I go somewhere for
the weekend and how does it work with
the quarantine do they tell you when the
quarantine is gonna start like could I
have time to come back home how do you
walk your dog if you have a quarantine I
don't know maybe perhaps maybe hmm
something I think about yeah so I wonder
how the logistics work like if there's
going to be a quarantine Digitas happen
in one instance or you're like tomorrow
quarantine so you have time to get home
and like pack your things
I guess so I'm torn as always like right
in the middle of being like should I be
panicked or are people being crazy and I
keep seeing things that's swaying me
both way and it ways and I just joined
the toaster screw the corona by de toast
and that's just making me like even
more so I saw that Twitter threatened
that's that's making me more and more
freaked out and I just don't know if
we're being insane or like we're not
being insane enough yeah I don't know
either I'm going back and forth but I do
think like the moral of the story here
being wash your hands more and more is a
great one
yeah I know I have now every time I come
home from the outside even if it's just
walking Theo I always watch my hands
which I never really did before which I
don't know if that's gross but I didn't
yet know now every time like I always
wash my hands when I got home but now
it's the first thing I do when I got get
home even if I just go take out my trash
wash my hands like my hands are so
chafed but hopefully that's really I'll
take a small president what else I
realized yesterday I went to brunch and
I didn't wear makeup because I was
getting my skin a break and when I don't
wear makeup I touch my face so much
we're wearing makeup might be the thing
that saves me because when I have makeup
on I don't touch my face oh I feel like
I touched my face more because I'm
always having like bristles like stuck
in my nose and and lipstick no moving
around I'm sitting at the table with my
face
on my hands oh yeah I would never do
what I was right makeup I was rubbing my
eyes oh god I was being so crazy because
I wasn't wearing makeup and now it's
like we have no choice but to wear
makeup yeah I guess the makeup industry
is the only one benefiting from this and
the hand sanitizer industry yes there's
an final story
Madison beer urges people to stop
shaming women after detailing her own
experience so Madison beer took to
Twitter yesterday to share a statement
that was actually like just really sad
but inspiring because when she was 14
there was a video that went sort of
viral of her like nude you know a
scenario that she had sent to her
boyfriend um and now the video and like
for the past seven years it's just
caused her a lot of anxiety like when
it's gonna come up sure
um and it's been like going around again
so what she discussed like the trauma
that she had experienced because of the
video and saying that it was not okay
and today on International Women's Day
she's freeing herself of the shame of
this video because um that's so sad I
didn't know that it still followed her
around I remember when I was like a
really big fan of hers like when we were
much younger and it happened it was like
such a big scandal and people where
wasn't sure if it was her and they were
like matching the nail color to a nail
color she was once seen wearing that's
so sad
yeah she said today on International
Women's Day I'm going to free myself of
this weight that I carry
gonna tell my 14 year old self the
following which I hope may help some of
you be kinder to yourselves as young
women you should not feel shame you were
exploring your sexuality you were
learning you should not feel like you
did something wrong shame on those who
betrayed your trust
and shame on those who shamed you shame
on those who betrayed your trust
also at 14 like this is child
pornography and anybody who is sharing
that video like should be arrested
rested that's so true I didn't I never
even think about that element when it
comes to like people's that's a thing
with them all the tick stalkers now like
if you are famous on tik tok someone's
like finding your dick pic and the kids
are so young that it really is
considered child pornography that's so
[ __ ] out it's so disgusting
I love Madison B oh did you see her
birthday party this weekend it was
star-studded like part of me thinks that
she's dating david dobrik and part of me
like wants to cry about it but it's like
I also really happy for them that he's
posted where he like shows that the
rumor that he's dating Madison beer and
he was so excited about it yeah and I
don't like it just it's really hard for
me like to be such a big day of a dark
fan because like now all he does is like
hang out with models and Madison Beer
says snatch her birthday party you have
to see this picture she looks like a
Victoria's Secret Angel it's just hard
for me like because then it just makes
him feel like less like my friend and
more like you know someone I'm never
gonna be friends with but your model
that's true I do have a shoot today yeah
and like I think it was what news
article called Yamato Oh Myrtle yeah
you're right you're right it was a very
small British newspaper that referred to
me as a model once and I will never
forget it I should actually have that
like printed I should get a copy of that
original newspaper and frame it I think
that you should I forget what the story
was on but oh my god I have been getting
tagged I have a Google Alert on myself
obviously and I have been getting
notified about this lawsuit against
jewel that my name is in excuse me there
is this lawsuit I don't know who's suing
you but jewel is being sued for
illegally marketing against teenagers
and intentionally trying to like make
them into customers and they're saying
that they contacted celebrities like
Cara Delevingne and influencers like
Claudia astray which by the way I've
literally never been contacted by jewel
or worked with them in any formal
capacity but I'm in this like I'm in
this deposition it's so weird Jule
schmoozed with teen friendly celebs and
influencers ranging from Miley Cyrus
Robert Pattinson
and Kristen Stewart took Claudia ashtray
okay Wow I'm living for just like the
sentence that I'm a part of a hundred
percent but I'm here to clear my name
okay not that I'm like not living for
this press like when you've had bad
press like you will take what you can
get so this is nothing I I'm here this
is my official song really a part of
this this isn't like it's in court Docs
Wow I know oh my god good for you
thank you obviously that I'm here to say
it's not true I hope they subpoena me or
something then it could be like
paparazzi you'll be like sitting next to
Miley being like this is crazy
like can you believe we're here again I
was like this is crazy right yeah yeah
oh my god
they'll be still iconic like me drooling
in the courtroom love that love that
well those were the fast five stories
that you needed to know when I do feel
as though you meet you didn't need to
know those stories you definitely did
you also need to know our thoughts on
Shahs of Sunset cuz they moved to
Fridays but do you think that means um I
think it's just like shark tank just
like Damon said you know the fan spoke
yeah but I'm the chasis ever been on
Friday and to me a Friday night slot on
Bravo it's not good I love a Friday
night show like dynasties on Fridays and
then I have all weekend to watch it even
though this weekend I happen not to
watch it i watch i recap the last this
season of curb so far because we were
talking about it I'm at dinner and I'd
rather die in the Sea of Cortez that
none of you know what I weigh okay so
let's do our TV recap brought to you by
thrive market which is a great
membership that everyone should be a
part of so our market is an online
membership based market on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone you can enjoy members only
saving prices up to 25% off traditional
retail prices you can get free gifts
samples and deals every day with the
highest quality healthy and sustainable
products you can buy wholesome food home
and beauty products curated just for
your members their members find
everything you need from organic and
non-gmo food clean beauties safe
supplements and non-toxic home products
plus ethical meet sustainable seafood
clean wine and more it's healthy
shopping without the hassle you can shop
by more than 70 diets and values like
keto paleo gluten free vegan non-gmo
Fairtrade certified bpa-free and more
you can shop in the app where you skip
the store and the lines it's good for
you and the planet you can get free
shipping on orders of more than $49 and
they are delivered with fast carbon
neutral shipping from their zero waste
warehouse the best part of being a
member of thrive market is that once you
join they'll give through thrive gives
their one-for-one membership matching
program every paid membership sponsor is
a free one
for a low-income family so if you want
to eat good feel good to good and be
good go to thrive market dot-com / toast
to give thrive market a try you can
choose the membership model that best
fits your lifestyle they have one month
3 month and 12 month options to check it
out go to thrive market dot-com / toast
to get up to $20 off today we love that
you can choose your membership term for
us we went with a 12 month membership
because it comes down to just five
dollars a month but if you're not sure
if thrive market is the right fit for
you you can easily give it a try for a
shorter period of time
just remember thrive market membership
is risk free you can take the first 30
days to determine if thrive market is
right for you if it's not just cancel
within 30 days and get a full refund
love thrive market you guys okay such
great healthy snacks yeah they have
smart sweets on there which is like my
favorite snack okay let's chop shots it
was really frustrating episode for me
because I'm at the point in the season
where I'm like disliking everyone which
I hate an MJ has not been on I know
she's busy but like to me she's the
heart and soul of the show and I need
her and I love Tommy and I just love
Vita like I love their whole thing and
they're never on yeah her absence is
keenly felt and we're just relying on
this dumb drama between like Nima and
Mike who honestly a can't pick a side
because honestly towards the end of the
fight like Mike was wrong but I hate
Nima so I I think Nima so thirsty I
haven't liked him from the second he got
on the show he was so visibly thirsty
that for his first season and now he's
just like in his new apartment with his
veneers and he's just so like Persian
reality star and he's like loving it and
he's bothering me so Mike totally agree
what he said about Polina and her kids
was so [ __ ] up and I don't think what
Mike said about whatever her name is his
ex-girlfriend was even bad at all but it
was also his ex-girlfriend like to
compare what Mike just saying that he
was leading that Nima was leading his
ex-girlfriend on to questioning why
paulina would be with Mike and let
Paulinus kids like what what Nima said
was so [ __ ] up but Mike then getting
mad at Nima for sitting down with
paulina is is so stupid like it's Mike's
responsibility to know that his
girlfriend reached out to Nima and he
wasn't even mad at his girlfriend he was
just mad at Nieman EEMA assumed that
Mike knew about the meeting which I
totally agree I thought make knew about
the meeting too so I couldn't take
either one of their sides because Mike
was wrong but I just don't like Nima
yeah I don't think they they needed to
meet like I think they're gonna meet
that makes you be there that's [ __ ]
weird yeah but I liked Pauline I just
mean like you're talking about my kids
let's have lunch say to my face like I
just like
throat I also think that's like she's
ready to be on the show it was very
ready to be on the show of her yeah but
I mean I love that I don't want to see
someone like a significant other on a
show who's not ready to be on the show
and I have a huge pit about this
construction project that he's working
on with his brothers like taking his
brothers money who like his brothers are
both doctors like they work really hard
taking their money
I mean he's being so hell-bent on being
in charge of the project in charge of
the project using his contractor using
his electrician like I have a huge pit I
have such a pig they should sell the
property they've had it for a few years
they'll make a huge return on it they
don't need to be the ones making it into
a development he's a reality star he's
busy enough he's in no way capable not
even because he's like there's anything
wrong with him like most people wouldn't
be able to take on a project project of
that scale as their first construction
contracting project I totally agree I'm
such a pig it's not even if he tries and
wakes up every day and gets there before
everyone like it could still go wrong
because like he can't even foresee the
prop like he has most weather even the
most seasoned developer has problems no
but even the most seasoned developer
they got their start on something small
they make the mistakes they learn the
things they need to learn you don't have
your learning experience on something
this big check it's such a pit every
time they see know me too and like it
for his family like for his mother and I
love Mike but like that's delusional and
Mike is not contributing financially so
he's saying like I will contribute my
time and it's like actually can you not
please it's really frustrating to watch
um
the destiny Sarah some unstuff I talk
like I'm Persian now because like her
name's Sarah but they call her Sarah um
it's really frustrating to me I don't
know why like the season everyone's
turning on destiny when like everyone
loved her last season and I love her and
she seems like she's like in this cool
place in her life where she's being
carefree and Sarah is so judgmental and
obviously didn't like the fact that um
destiny hooked up with her brother but
like who cares they're all adults and
Sarah doesn't Jesse doesn't owe anything
to Sarah Sarah was mean to her the first
time they met they're not friends and
GG's all being like did you talk to
Sarah about the fact that you hooked up
with her brother why they're not friends
gross why would she talk about her to be
honest like she's better friends with
the brother than she is Sarah Sarah was
me to her the first time they met and
Sarah openly was like I don't like des
yeah great and if they're not gonna like
date Hereafter they don't need to talk
about the fact that they hooked up let's
really let sleeping dogs lie yeah he
lives in Vegas like maybe she'll see him
when he she comes to town to visit her
mom but like I I just don't understand
the whole thing like everyone coming for
destiny
and it gets worse next episode because
that's where MJ finally returns to the
group and they have a party at Sara's
house and all the problems everyone's
problems just come to the come to the
table and I think this is where the MJ
and Reza friendship officially ends and
then everything that happens like with
Tommy ruining his yard I think all that
happens because of what happens at this
party yeah cuz right now like Reza and
MJ like they're not seeing eye-to-eye
but it hasn't blown up yet yeah and
they're like it's just so painful for me
because I have been like a Reza Stan
through the whole show and even when him
and MJ have fought in the past I've
always been on Reza's side but I'm not
yeah like at all
me neither it's really hard for me yeah
it's hard um okay curb watching episode
of course I'm like I spent last night
catching up I guess it was like the last
three episodes the Jon Hamm so funny
it's just been so good if you guys don't
watch like I don't know when I started
watching it my friends growing up always
watched it and I never did and I never
really got it I thought it was like that
Seinfeld tumor and I honestly don't love
Seinfeld
but to me curb is so much better than
Seinfeld and I got into it when it was
coming back I was like I should watch
this he is you and I watched them all on
prime and it was so funny it's so funny
it's a little bit of a frustrating show
to watch because like Larry like some of
his things that make him so crazy like
bothering me so much and sometimes the
episodes get to in the weeds I'm like a
specific joke but for the most part it's
so well done and this most recent
episode when we went out to dinner on
Saturday night I couldn't stop talking
about I've been talking about it with
anyone because to me it was the best
episode of TV I've ever seen it's when
they go to that guy Mickey's wedding in
Mexico and they don't really want to go
but they say they'll charter a plane so
he has to get everyone's waits for the
plane because when you fly private they
have like balance all the weight of the
luggage in the weight of the people and
obviously nobody wants to give him his
weight and Susie who's Jeff's wife who
was by the way the best character back
it took me years to realize it I didn't
realize it until a few weeks ago she's
at what she and I can't leave until I
said because they're giving her more
lines than more and she said to Larry I
literally I was watching it when we were
in the Delta Sky Lounge right before we
saw Lancelot like have you saw me dying
I would rather die in the Sea of Cortez
then have you know what I weigh I was
dying
it was literally such a funny episode
and this whole season has been really
funny like a lot a Larry step is
but to me like that was like just the
culmination of just like comedy yeah a
hundred percent I say Larry stop it
suddenly it's like a little annoying but
I really like this Jon Hamm episode two
and Jonathan was handsome and he's so
funny like you would think he's so
serious because he's a Don Draper but
he's just such a goofball I love him I
want him to be on the show more also
it's crazy that Vince Vaughn is on the
show now is Freddie Funkhouser and they
never addressed the fact that Marty
Funkhouser died Oh
the actor died actor yeah and so they
just said that Marty's in China that's
weird
yeah well I I guess what are they gonna
do a funny show they don't wanna yeah
and Richard Lewis is Stan okay me
neither and then Richard Lewis's Ben's
favorite character and like I don't like
him I don't like him either but then
sometimes he's just like a funny foil
for Larry because he's like the total
opposite but like with his rectal
bleeding ya know but sometimes he used
uh zijn get white Larry so crazy about
on the count of three let's say the
worst character on the show when we
think back to old seasons - okay um okay
one two three Cheryl oh I [ __ ] hate
her
ya know she's so annoying like who gives
up Larry David and by the way her
hooking up was you know dancing is the
exact same thing as him hooking up with
her so sir
you know what he did was worse but
because he did a second it's not as bad
yeah and you know what like you he's
moved on yeah and they don't have kids
like Ted Danson [ __ ] Ted Danson and you
[ __ ] Ted Danson and that episode where
like they all are going to like a museum
and it's donated by anonymous and then
donated by Larry David and anonymous
ends up being Ted Danson yeah just touch
it but like it's just funny how like
these little nuances become like
full-blown comedy sketches like you
never really think about how when people
say I would really appreciate it like it
really makes a world of a difference
yeah you know it's just a really
well-done show I'm sure like everyone
knows that because it's been the bigger
shot television just know what you
happen to like not watch it or are not
caught up like this season is so [ __ ]
good it's so good and the ugly section
was such a good room attendant you guys
this is just this is a necessary
conversation we need to be having the
bathroom attendant has been like a topic
on many a comedy like platform I
remember the first special I saw of Amy
Schumer she did a whole thing about a
bathroom attendant like with her hands
walking it's really funny I think that
there and ahead I like about them a
10-man I think when it's in like a club
situation where there's always like
rotating things rotating people then
it's fine but if it is like a lunchtime
place and it's a bathroom where you
would be alone and like you are going
number two like no there's no need let's
take a break for these sirens can we
just me
sorry about that there was a mature
siren hope everyone's okay and you know
it got so crazy loud I'm really glad
that we paused but all in all what we're
trying to say it was chopped sunset was
not good this week Curb Your Enthusiasm
especially on television and we know
that everyone already knew that but
we're just learning so thanks for
staying with us yeah I'm just having
like a curb appreciation moment you know
we also don't have guests this week
which is crazy coming off of last week
but I'm I'm not upset about it
no I find guest episodes to obviously be
great like for our brand and for growth
and I love meeting new people but I get
nervous like I just want to like run
through this show which I hate rushing
through the show and then I want like
the guests to be happy it's like a lot
of pits and then like the guest is never
talking into their mic which I can't
yeah we'll have guests the following
week but I think this week is just a
toast appreciation week which is great
also with coronavirus coming around like
it's probably better that we don't have
guests agreed you know cuz that way
hopefully we don't have to shut down
this office that would be crazy
I'll be done we got so much yes what
would we do if we got quarantine we
would do it like over the phone somehow
I mean like it would use our integrated
interface yeah we use that integrated
interface in a mad long time yeah but I
guess that means like even if you had to
say your house and I had to say I mind
like we could still do the toast the
toast will go on yeah of course so in
tienen news we have a new episode today
coming out of day night with Raven and
Adam we have new episodes this whole
week of all of our shows snatchers gonna
be recapping the bachelor finale tonight
we have DNA with or even Adam mood with
Lauren Elizabeth Margaret Joseph's has a
new episode Wednesday believe she has a
guest coming on and we are launching a
new show this week this week so we'll be
announcing it today and the new episode
I think we decided to drop on Thursday
so it's very exciting some of you have
guessed it it's gonna be a really good
show so make sure you're following totes
news network on Instagram to keep up
with all of our new shows thank you so
much for listening to the morning to us
the Millennial morning show where we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube so if you're
watching us on YouTube currently please
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available to podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that Spotify
iTunes stitcher Public Radio I our
videocast box all the places wherever
you choose to find podcasts find us the
morning shows hi maybe you want to
subscribe leave a five star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we could go for a subscription and if I
serve you and you know who else could go
for a subscription and a five-star view
the redheads there's a new episode drop
it on Thursday so go Cod he actually had
dinner with the redheads and aren't Lea
just such an exciting bunch to be around
a beulas gang you know I didn't realize
I had this lunch dinner reservation and
it was for like a bunch of people and
then all the people cancelled so I was
like who can I get to come and it
like I was basically just like crashing
like your guys's dinner party cuz like
some of Ben's friend supposed to come
but then it just ends up being like all
Jackie and her friends and then like me
and Ben but I think was fine yeah oh
yeah totally fine yeah it was such a
good meal like tea and family you didn't
Sam it was at Castaic which is so good I
ate so much it was so delicious it was
so delicious
tell you guys check out the redheads
even if you didn't read the book like I
think you could still enjoy the episode
and if you are keeping up with the
readings make sure to finish up so you
can listen to this month's episode it's
an hour and twenty minutes like if you
need to kill that day like you know
where to go I'm in the redheads Facebook
group and a bunch of there was a post
with a bunch of people commenting about
how their phone screen time is down
since they started reading so much and I
thought that was so nice I love that's
the sort of [ __ ] that I love to see and
actually when we were in LA Claudia and
I were comparing phone screen time
terrible and Claudia had days even the
day where we both traveled your number
was you to get Wi-Fi on the plane and I
did well cuz I just don't so super
watching stuff on our iPads and then on
the way back I ride the whole time and
it's just like it's everything of a sort
I actually read a new book this weekend
called the jet setters and while I
thought it was gonna be like a fabulous
book about jet setters yeah um it really
wasn't but it was quite interesting to
know it was rustic but it was actually
it was really good I mean it's Reese's
book club of the month so like obviously
it's gonna be good I really liked it and
I would recommend I would give it a 4
out of 5 though because I'm not rolling
out those fives anymore like snitch says
dead okay you guys have a great day
we'll see you tomorrow tomorrow and
tomorrow you're only
[Music]